hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology Q&A
for kids and others and
um I
see whole
variety of questions here I see one from
Rudy how is it that animal species all
look relatively similar at least similar
across a breed example dogs G retrievers
yet all humans have unique
features I think that that is purely in
the eye of the beholder I think that we
humans have
incredibly well-tuned capabilities to
distinguish faces this presumably is of
evolutionary value and uh you know to
tell who's who so to speak and we just
don't have that for other species in
fact even I will I will say within
humans you know if you
are kind of I don't know when I've when
I've traveled
to other countries with with uh I'm I'm
you know I'm kind of like I can tell the
the you know the westerners who look a
bit like me apart much more easily than
I can tell other folks apart I'm
particularly bad at face recognition but
I think that's a a pretty common
phenomenon that that when one has seen
many examples of similar kinds of uh the
kinds of things that's it's easier to
tell them apart than when one hasn't
seen so many examples um and I think in
the case of uh as I say we humans really
just have very well-tuned
capabilities to tell human faces apart
and I suspect if you're a
um you know if if you are uh if if
you're a person who keeps a lot of cats
I'm sure you can tell Cat Face apart
better than the average person so I I
think it's it's um I I would speculate
that if you were to make measurements on
sort of cat faces human faces whatever
else um that the same level of that we
will be surprised at how uh how small
the variations have to be in the
structure of human faces for us to tell
them apart and that we just aren't as
well able to tell apart other kinds of
uh uh faces
um Sabrina is commenting here that they
have a fraternal twin who some people
say looks identical but others say look
nothing alike yeah i' I've uh um you
know even for identical twins I know one
collection of identical
triplets where they uh you know to me
they look the same and but to people who
know them well they absolutely do not um
so I think I think that's one of these
uh uh it's in the eye of the beholder
now now there's this
question of I mean this whole issue
about um even the case of identical
twins with the same
genetics there are and I think we talked
about this another time there are these
epigenetic features that cause the the
actual final organism to be different
and that's even true at the level of you
know the the fingerprints and the uh you
know Iris patterns in the eye those are
things which are essentially sort of
physical processes that form those
particular um shapes and so on that go
beyond what is just the The genome just
says things like you mix these two
fluids together and that's how you'll
make this thing but the actual physics
of how those mix is something that is
determined by all kinds of detailed
thermal effects and so on and um is not
or chemical reaction effects and so on
and has sort of uh additional Randomness
from the environment that is not carried
in the genome so there are these things
that are features of the kind of
um uh just in the the sort of
construction of the organism um as it
grows and then once you know in the case
of human U identical twins and things
like that once they're sort of out and
about
then all sorts of differences in the
environments in which they happen to
exist and the way that they you know I
suspect when there's a small change that
that change is often Amplified because
of the effect of that change on the
particular personalities of the of the
twins or whatever else and I'm sure the
same is true with the you know litters
of animals and things like this anyway
so my my my my uh feeling is that
it's a it's an illusion that these
things look the same and others don't I
mean I I I would say that this whole
question
about what's kind of a feature of what
we observe versus what's there in
reality this is something that is
interesting in lots of different kinds
of cases something that I think is
deeply of interest in understanding how
physics emerges in our physics project
all kinds of things like this but that
will get us um uh that will get us into
a um another whole Rabbit Hole here let
me see
um a question here from eron about e the
exponential constant about
2.71828 Etc and what it is and uh how it
works um e is not what's usually called
Oilers constant that's a confusing thing
Leonard oer did start talking about e
the exponential constant but he has
another constant named after him the OA
mascheroni constant which is usually
denoted gamma and is about
0.577 so the the thing that's called
e is the exponential constant it's not
the um
uh that's not the um the same thing as
what's usually called oil as constant I
can explain both of them although
actually this is one of these things
where it' be a lot better if I was
actually showing you computationally
what's going on and maybe I can just
have a try here but maybe another time
uh I had started talking about sort of
explaining math computationally a few
weeks ago and we got as far as algebra
and I promised I would do this again and
get as far as calculus and as we get
into calculus we will encounter e uh in
a in an interesting way but let me kind
of roughly explain it um the uh the
question is if you draw a curve and you
say let's say it's a curve this value as
a function of time and it's some some
thing as a function of time it might
wiggle up it might go down it might do
all kinds of things but let's say it's
going up like a
power of like like something to the
power of the time so it's two to the
power of the time three to the power of
the time something something like this
so every every unit of time we go from
time equals 1 to time equals 2 we're
going let's say that our function is 2
to the T from from uh time actually
let's say it's 10 to the T from time one
to time two to time three every every
unit of time the value of the function
is getting multiplied by 10 and the so
we'll get 10 1 10 2 10 the 3 that's you
know 10 100 a th000 etc etc
Etc okay so we got this curve it's going
up like this and we we can ask the
question what's the area under that
curve and
the
answer is that the area under the Curve
will be some other function just like if
we had a if we had a a curve that was
just flat constant then the area under
that curve is a linear function because
as we as we just we're we're sweeping
out more and more of what's under the
curve and that's giving us sort of
higher and higher area so the area will
just go up linearly um well in the case
of of powers the area goes up like a
power but turns out that it doesn't the
there's only one power for which the
area goes up and it's the same function
as the original curve and that's the
case where the um where the the
um uh where the where the base is this
exponential constant that's not a very
good explanation we we got to see it on
a computer sorry this is uh this is much
easier to understand on on a
computer
um let's
see
uh gosh Brady is asking in the spirit of
Halloween which just passed is there any
science behind ghostly appearances well
gosh
um you
know back
in Victorian times 130 40 years ago
people would constantly be doing things
where they would talk about the aura
associated with a person and I think
even they would they would do things
like say let's have uh let's let's have
this um piece of photographic film we
take a photograph and we think the
person looks like this but actually when
we develop the photograph there's all
this extra stuff around the person now
that's really just I think a detail in
most cases there of the way that the the
the photograph was made and the way it
was developed and so on but you can ask
the question is there more associated
with a person so to speak than we can
see and to some extent well yes because
there are for example electric fields
that are you know there is it's not very
big but uh you know whenever we move our
muscles for example there that's an
electrical phenomenon and so there is
sort of an electrical effect that you
can in principle detect in the case of
uh you know the heart we do EKG which is
detecting electrically the contraction
of muscles in the heart and or we do we
look at um uh brain activity with EEG
we're looking at the electrical activity
of neurons in the brain and in general
we can we can measure if you put
electrical sensors on on a muscle you
can detect the uh the kind of um the
contraction of the muscle which is an
electrically induced effect um with
Those sensors so one could certainly
imagine you know one is not paying
attention to any of the light coming
from a person so to speak you know any
of the reflected light but one could
measure just the electrical effects for
instance now the electrical effects are
small and they're usually not measured
except by by by actual contact with with
the with the skin and so on um but there
is some small electromagnetic effect of
kind of the things that cells do and the
things we do uh in in our sort of
standard operations that's an example of
something where you could in principle
detect that and that would give you a
kind of a a different view of of um uh
of humans even looking at us in the
infrared um where we're looking at the
heat generated by us humans different
parts of our bodies are at different
temperatures um because they have
different blood flow to them and they
have different uh uh the the the the
blood our blood is more or less at
constant temperature because it's being
circulated around in our bodies but um
by the time when when uh it can be cold
on the surface because the uh the the
the heat is not
diffusing uh adequately to the surface
from the internal sort of core
temperature associated with the blood um
now I suppose in in um uh let's see
we're we're we're kind of wondering you
know you've got your haunted house for
example and um you've got kind of the uh
uh what's kind of left over from the
folks who lived there before and uh um
what's kind of what could possibly still
be there so to speak and I think much of
that is uh uh a thing to to realize okay
so here here's a here's a a a a feature
of that you could say
well you know in in um when it comes
down to the level of individual
molecules for example there is
surprisingly uh surprising amounts of
molecules are very small and there's a
surprising amount of mixing of of these
molecules or even anything that's very
small can get mixed a lot like for
example in the pandemic that we all
lived through um the uh uh you could ask
the question you know all those little
virus particles those virus particles
were 100 billionths of a um 100
nanometers in in size they they were um
uh one 10 millionth of a meter um across
and so very small and you could ask the
question all those viruses that infected
all those people around the world um if
you just put them in a box how big would
they end up being and the answer well I
remember early in the pandemic I worked
this out and it was about the size of
one's fist I think probably by later in
the pandemic probably got to be the size
of a you know a small box like this but
because they're so small by the time
that you can get and because just an you
know just a few virus particles or
enough
potentially to cause an infection
presumably the um uh you know you can
you can take that kind of box of stuff
and you can there enough virus particles
in there that when you spread them out
across the world so to speak you can uh
sort of you can get everywhere with
those virus particles so it ends up you
know these these statements like uh if
you take um oh I don't know the
um any old you know glass of water that
somebody drank at some some point then
the molecules there are enough water
molecules in that glass of water and
water gets mixed enough in the kind of
uh what happens in the in the climate
and the atmosphere in the oceans and so
on that in not too long the individual
water molecules from that particular cup
of water the the next cup of water you
drink is probably going to have one of
those very same molecules in it um just
because the of the way that things mix
uh mix around
I suppose the
uh uh yeah so I'm not I'm not really
doing very well on on uh on making my
Halloween Theory here but but that's uh
perhaps a few
comments let's see
um Giovani asks if an advanced
civilization lived on earth one billion
years ago would there be any signs of
their existence in today's
time in question I
think
that well I would say that let's assume
it's our civilization so let's say we
took our civilization and we transported
it back to a billion years ago and we
built our roads and we built our
skyscrapers and we built all these kinds
of
things would there be any sign of this a
billion years later I think the answer
is yes um just
as rocks basically last a long time and
when things get turned into fossils they
get turned into fossils usually because
there's there's some soft thing and that
soft thing kind of makes an impression
on where the rock is going to be formed
and then the rock really stays there for
a very very long time and you know rocks
we certainly have rocks well on the on
the moon the rocks from from when the
moon was formed 4.6 billion years ago
are still Exposed on the surface and the
Earth for a couple of reasons one
because of the atmosphere and erosion
and so on and two because of the liquid
core of the earth and uh kind of
volcanic activity and so on the The
Rocks tend to get sort of turned over
and there are fewer places on the
surface of the Earth where there are
rocks from billions of years ago Exposed
on the surface but the Rocks still get
they they maintain a lot of their
integrity and that's why we can still
find fossils going back okay it's
microfossils back from two billion years
ago but it's still can still find sort
of evidence of what was happening sort
of as as defined by its impression left
in rock because Rock just stays a long
time and the things we've built the
concrete in our buildings and things
like this the stone walls we built and
so on it's just rocks and rocks last a
billion years and so I think we would
see that kind of evidence of what uh our
civilization looked like I mean if we
imagine that sort of all the people
disappeared and everything was left
derelict so to speak all sorts of things
would happen I mean you know if the
plants are still around the uh there'd
be a lot of encroachment of of plants on
on the kind of on the infrastructure
that we leave behind a lot of things
would rust and Decay but but the things
that are rock like like concrete and so
on um or for that matter Stone buildings
uh would kind of stay
up to the point where things you know
there might be earthquakes that will
make the stone buildings fall down there
might be uh uh gradually you know you
see in places um I've seen in you know
old very old stone constructions where
trees grow through the stone
construction and eventually push things
out of the way but that's a fairly
gradual process and my my guess is that
a lot of the things we've made that are
sort of stonik would would stay for a
really long time and that the things we
made would would would be preserved now
people worry about that examples of
things which one wants to be preserved
like for instance in places where
there's radioactive waste that's been uh
been tried to be stored um it's like can
we make a storage system that will sort
of stay keep its Integrity for well then
it's more modestly 10,000 years or
something um and and how will that work
out but I think the the more challenging
issue is okay given our civilization
projected back a billion years and and
would we you know would we be able to
find sort of our civilization I think
the answer is probably yes but if you
say could we find that there was a
civilization or something that we would
call a
civilization from millions of years ago
and you know could we tell that that
happened I think that's much less
convincing I think that you know when we
look at the dinosaurs or something and
we see that there's some place where
there's lots of dinosaur footprints and
you know we find them and then you could
say well it was that a ritual dance of
the dinosaurs where they were worshiping
some dinosaur God and or was that just a
herd of dinosaurs doing something like
what what we think modern animals are
doing I think that's really hard to
answer you know if we say did the
dinosaurs make artifacts that are
recognizable to us that's something
where we can say well doesn't look like
it but you say artifacts recognizable to
the dinosaurs or sort of a this is a
very challenging thing I mean we see
that now oh for example these puffer
fish that spend a week kind of making
these very elaborate Mandela like
patterns in the sand and then they
destroy them again but they make this
very elaborate pattern and maybe those
get fossilized and you look at one of
these things you say is that a Mandela
that was made by you know the the uh I
don't know Buddhist monks or something
or was that a a pattern made by this
puffer fish and you know you say the
Buddhist monks are doing the thing which
is very much derived from a whole
elaborate sort of course of civilization
and so on and the puffer fish well we
assume that there isn't an elaborate
sort of uh uh oral tradition of puffer
fish passing down the how to create this
Mandela types pattern but it's some kind
of genetically determined feature of
puffer fish that they can that they can
do that and um but I think it's a really
subtle thing to know it's a it's a very
very interesting question you know how
do how does one know what something
created for a purpose really that ends
up only being defined when we start sort
of having a way of connecting the
purposes that we internally understand
to what we can see happen in that system
and you know this relates again to
things like AIS where the AI is just
doing something and you know it's
Computing something and we look at it
and we say is that is it is it trying to
do something or is it just randomly
flapping around doing sort of arbitrary
computations and that question of of
sort of is it aligned with our human
kind of conceptions of what one should
be doing is that's a challenging thing
to Define but it's an important thing to
Define if we're trying to say we want AI
to only do things which are aligned with
certain things humans want to do versus
we'll let them do arbitary computations
and so on so just a a few thoughts about
that
um let's
see
uh well kinds of questions here um Peter
is asking how does photography work how
are we able to capture an image so
easily whether on film or on a phone
screen
so what's happening in photography
basically we're trying to take light and
we're trying to somehow have the fact
that light fell on something be a thing
that's permanently recorded in the
thing so what is light there different
ways to to think about light but we can
think about light as a stream of photons
a stream of particles of light and we
can also in a sort of complimentary way
we can think about it as this kind of
electromagnetic wave but for these
purposes here let's think of it as just
a stream of photons and so the question
is a photon falls on something how does
that change the nature of the thing okay
so what was discovered in uh uh back in
the
1800s was that if you had a particular
chemical silver
iodide that when a photon of light hit
that piece of silver iodide it would
take that molecule which was a silver
and an iodine atom and it would somehow
kick the silver atom out and so it would
make a chemical change basically to that
um uh to that molecule so you would
cover a piece of uh paper or something
with lots of silver iodide and then you
would have uh then you have the photon
of light would in some places it would
hit that when whe Whenever there was
light it would whatever light fell on
that particular on that piece of paper
and it it would hit this sodium uh
silver iodide and it would kick the
silver atom just a little bit out okay
so then what you had to do was to
develop the film and that's a chemical
process that would take the um uh
um uh the the the um
um
take that small chemical effect and make
it actually show up as a change of color
and I'm now forgetting how the change of
color worked um but but basically the
idea is you've made a chemical change
and that chem chemical change can have
the effect of changing the color of
what's on the piece on on the page well
what what typically was done was in
places where the the light fell on the
film The iodine was kicked out and the
film went black in places where the
light didn't fall it would stay white or
so it was a film so it was transparent
and so in places where the light didn't
fall it would stay transparent in places
where the light did fall it would go
black now that's obviously the negative
of what we want we want it to be lighter
where the light fell and darker where
the light didn't fall so that meant that
what you would get initially is a
negative and then what you had to do was
to make a positive from the negative and
you would do that by essentially using
this same photographic process again you
would take the negative put it on
another on another sort of piece of
paper and then you would shine light
through the negative and then the places
where the light didn't fall would stay
is that the right way is that right you
would gosh I even did this when I was a
kid a bunch of times you would um uh you
would you take the negative film and um
which was what was sort of the camera
was this you know uh was this film that
when exposed to light would turn black
when not exposed to light would turn
white and then what is the process I
mean it's another chemical process that
allows you to sort of reverse that again
I think it's a very similar process to
the first one that allows you to reverse
that again and uh and and get the sort
of positive picture and that was for
black and white photography when you're
doing color photography the idea is that
well for the human eye we really just
detect the redness greenness and bless
of light light can have any kind of uh
uh sort
of configuration of of energies of
photons and so on but we just detect the
ones which are kind of in the red bucket
green bucket blue bucket and so one way
to deal with that is to just say well
let's make
three uh let's let's just have kind of
three separate we'll just use a filter
we'll have a a blue filter a green
filter a red filter um and will those
filters will let through only the red
light only the green light whatever then
we we have on our
um on our final film we have well one
way to do it was to actually have three
passes where we're having something
which will put the red color the green
color the blue color down I mean in a
sense that's what happens in in like a
laser printer color laser printer you've
literally got you know the granules of
well it's actually for for what you when
you print it's not red green blue It's s
magenta yellow um which are the
complimentary colors um but you've
literally got you know a thing of toner
granules of of something in each of
those
colors so okay that that's
that was a little bit on how photography
with film
Works um in the case of of uh something
like a um a digital camera um the way
that works is what you're doing is
instead of getting an actual sort of
image fixed on the um uh on the piece of
paper or the film what you're trying to
do is you're trying to say we have all
these pixels in our image we might have
I don't know in a modern camera there
might be 10 million pixels so we're
dividing the uh you know the the the
image the lens of the camera causes what
you see in the outside world to be an
image of that to be formed on
essentially the retina of the camera on
the on the um on on this detector that's
an array of little tiny cells let's say
10 million of them okay so how do the
individual cells work what they're
trying to do is produce an electrical
signal
when light when a photon of light falls
on that particular Square uh on that
particular pixel in the in the array and
these are usually they're called charge
coupled devices and um that's the most
common type of detector but essentially
what's happening is it's a little bit
like the silver iodide story where the
photon comes in and it kicks the silver
atom out in the case of uh these kind of
charge couble devices what's basically
happening is the photon comes in and it
kicks an electron out it's essentially
the um well it's kind of an analogue of
the photoelectric effect which was the
the big giveaway that photons existed
that Einstein talked about in 1905 and
so on but it's sort of the same idea
Photon comes in it sort of kicks an
electron out we then get to detect that
electron being sort of kicked out as an
electrical signal and so then we know
that pixel at the pixel at this position
uh was um uh was kind of had a photon
fall on it so that's so light has fallen
there and and the way it works with
color um uh color cameras is there's a
bunch of pixels and some pixels have a
little red filter in front of them some
have a green filter some have a blue
filter and you're just looking at which
pixels did you get did you get uh in a
particular place did you get was it the
red pixels that had the electrons kicked
out of them or was it the green pixels
and that tells you what the color is
because it it's if it's like um you know
red and green together you've got yellow
light that will produce both red and
green will be active and so on and um
the so in fact what that means is that
for example if you change this kind of
filters that are in front of these
pixels you could actually detect a a
larger range of colors for example you
could more finely uh detect what the ACT
ual photons that are arriving are and
that gives you what it's called
hyperspectral Imaging where you're able
to to say more than just saying oh it's
roughly red or rough it's roughly this
color as humans perceive color and
that's relevant if you're trying to like
identify a material lots of things where
to us it's just oh that's white well
actually it's not really white it's just
that it has roughly the same amounts of
red green and blue with our definitions
of red green and blue but if you were to
look look more finely at kind of the
frequencies of light that are produced
you would see some some whole
complicated uh pattern of that and you
would be able to much more tell what
that thing that just looks white to us
is made of just like we can tell some
substances apart by the colors that we
perceive there's a sort of finer grain
version of that and it's been a thing
where people haven't yet produced these
in a really Industrial Way hyperspectral
cameras um you can get hyperspectral
cameras they're used particularly for
things like uh telling whether food has
gone bad or not because it's like well
I've got something and it looks like
this piece of meat and it kind of looks
to us it looks kind of the same it
doesn't look any different but if you
look in a more fine grained way in a
hyperspectral way then you can tell that
it really changed color and people had
imagined that you could do that for
things with Dermatology telling whether
you know that spot on your skin which
just looks Brown to us what its precise
spectrum is and whether you could tell
was that a bad spot or a spot that
didn't matter or whatever else that
didn't I think pan out quite as well but
certainly for things like food uh
telling whether you know food's good or
not hyperspectral Imaging is used um
hyperspectral Imaging is used for some
other kinds of um material
identification telling whether crops
well the things like whether crops are
growing you tend to more need to use
things in the infrared and so on but
again this idea of you put this kind of
mass
in front of the uh the actual pixel
detectors and that tells you the color
so that that's how that roughly works
and by the way it's incredibly similar
to the way that our eyes work because at
the back of our eye in our retina there
is an array of photo detectors uh of
photo receptor cells it's roughly
they're all they're kind of roughly
circular cells and they pack them in and
there's kind of a hexagonal array
because just like coins you squash a
bunch of coins together they'll tend to
squash into a pattern that's roughly
hexagonal and same's true of the cells
in the back of our eye um and there sort
of this array of photo receptors and
depending on what position the photo
receptor is in on one's eye that's
saying oh there's a piece of light that
came from that part of our visual field
or a piece of that came from that part
and in the case of our eye there are we
have three kinds of uh so-called cone
cells three kinds of photo receptors
that detect different different uh
frequencies of photons different colors
of light and those correspond to the red
green blue uh sort of buckets of um of
of photons so that that's basically the
idea and um when it comes to other kinds
of
um oh other kinds of ways that you would
uh
uh sort of take visual input and do
things with it another another case is
things like photocopying or Laser
Printers um what happens in in photocopy
is is you've got you got your page and
what's done is that you
uh you use I think it's usually selenium
uh is the you have a kind of a slab of
that material and
you give
it how does this work I think you give
it an electric charge and then whenever
light fall WS on a particular
place it conducts the electricity and so
it gets rid of the electric charge in
that particular place so you've got this
plate and wherever light falls on the
plate and you charge up the plate and
then whenever light falls on a
particular place on the plate that
charge is conducted away and when it
doesn't fall the the um uh the the the
plate stays charged up stays
electrically charged and then you have
this thing called Tona which is
essentially plastic tiny plastic
granules and you kind of dusting those
across this plate and in places where
there's an electric charge they stick in
places where there isn't they don't
stick and so you get this plate that's
then uh kind of the image of your
original piece of paper or whatever and
you've got these pieces of toner that
stick on the plate in places where or
stick on where the where they were still
Electric charge so you've got this thing
it's still very fragile it's just a
bunch of plastic granules sticking on
top of this plate and then what you do
is you bake those plastic granules onto
a piece of paper so you put a piece of
paper in there and they're plastic
granules and they're sort of sitting
there and then you heat it up and those
plastic granules melt onto the piece of
paper and that's how you get your result
and so that's why when you have a laser
printer the paper comes out hot because
it just just had those plastic granules
baked onto the onto the uh onto the
paper and and and again this idea you
know if you look inside a color laser
printer you'll find there are well there
usually four little rep receptacles of
Tona there'll be cyan magenta yellow and
black those are the different colors
that are used to um uh that that you can
make sort of the black is sort of used
for convenience
that you add that in in principle you
could make that by combining the Canan
magenta and yellow but it would be a
muddy black typically and it's better to
have just a plain black by the way it's
reflecting very much the way that our
human visual system works because in
addition to the cone cells that detect
uh red green and blue we also have Rod
cells that essentially are detecting uh
black and white uh
um uh there so that's a rough
introduction ction to um uh how
photography Works let's see
um question
from
Jamie
uh let's see how do mirrors
work
um how why do they reflect things
mirrors uh what's happening in a mirror
is Photon comes in going in One
Direction Photon goes out in the
opposite direction so
normally anything any material is made
of a collection of atoms and when
photons interact with atoms they do it
well okay
photons I should
say okay in in an atom it's a little bit
more complicated here here so um photon
is coming in it's interacting with
material I should have said and
sometimes the photon is kind of interact
the way photons interact with matter is
through is the energy of photons that
corresponds to visible light is through
kind of kicking the electrons that exist
in the matter the nuclei of atoms are
not really they don't really pay
attention the the energy of photons of
visible light is not enough to do much
to the nuclei of atoms if you have gamma
rays x-rays things like that you can you
can do things to the nuclei of atoms but
with visible light you only get to uh to
sort of mess around with the with the
electrons in atoms and um the uh and so
what happens
is um in in a typical
material one always thinks of an atom
it's got its nucleus with protons and
neutrons it's got electrons kind of
outside the nucleus kind of going around
the nucleus in some sense um the nucleus
is is 100,00 times smaller than the
typical sort of distance from the
nucleus to the electrons and um the U
so
what uh in in different kinds of matter
one has this picture of nuclei of atoms
with electrons just hanging out around
that nucleus or a different thing that
can happen which is that the atoms can
share their electrons and so in general
when you have oh I don't know molecule
like water what's kind of the the
electrons are shared between the the
oxygen and the hydrogens in the water
and that's kind of how the water is is
is how those atoms are kind of glued
together in the water molecule now
metals have this feature that in a metal
the electrons are kind of shared across
all the atoms or at least some of the
electrons are shared across all the
atoms the so-called conduction band
where instead of the electrons being
localized to particular atoms the kind
of atoms are close enough together that
sort of all the places where the
electrons hang out they all merge and
the electrons kind of are free to float
from one side of the material to another
because they're not attached to an
individual atom and that's why that's
why um Metals conduct electr
is because their their electrons can
kind of roam freely and that means when
you put a voltage which is kind of a
push to the electrons electric field
that pushes the electrons they can kind
of roam freely through the material
without getting stuck atom to atom
whereas a an insulator as opposed to a
conductor um uh something like a I don't
know a piece of plastic or some piece of
wood something like this um the uh the
electrons are stuck within their atoms
and try as you might to push them out of
their atoms you you can't do that
eventually if you put a strong enough
electric field the material will break
down and the electrons will be ripped
out of their atoms but in the normal
course of things with just a little
battery or something the electrons will
be stuck in their atoms and you won't
conduct electricity okay what does this
have to do with with uh mirrors well in
a mirror you've got a metal and what's
happening is that the electrons the
photon comes in and kind of uh it's
let's see if I can actually explain this
it's um
uh this is a little bit subtle um the uh
well all right let's let's try this all
right so so first of all we have to
admit that light isn't quite just
photons it's it's we can think of light
as being a stream of these particles of
light
but kind of another way to think of it
is as an electromagnetic wave where we
have electric fields and magnetic fields
and they're kind of uh
continually uh kind of oscillating in
free space and that's that's an
electromagnetic field is light can also
be thought of as this wave of you know
magnetic field gets big electric field
gets big magnetic field gets big
electric field gets big and that kind of
wave of electromagnetism is another
version of light as opposed to thinking
of it as it's a it's a sort of a blob of
electromagnetic energy that's in this
Photon these are two complimentary ways
to look at light um they both you know
you can you can kind of see that they
might have some correspondence because
the photon is this kind of blob of
electromagnetic energy the wave is this
kind of description of the light as this
kind of uh whole collection of pieces of
electromagnetic energy and you can
imagine that the sort of stream of
photons that are blob blah blob blah
blob of of of photons is sort of
something that you could view as being a
bit like this thing that is the
electromagnetic wave this correspondence
between these two things is something
that gets more clearly understood in
quantum mechanics um but we don't need
to go there for these purposes so we've
got this electromagnetic field that is
the light that is uh that is um uh that
that hits this this metal plate let's
say this mirror and what happens is that
the electrons as a result of of uh uh
when this electromagnetic wave impinges
on the on the on the mirror it's causing
the electrons to be moved around in the
mirror uh the electric field is pushing
the electrons in certain direction
magnetic field is is moving them around
and what ends up happening is that gosh
this this relies on several different
things okay so another fact is that when
you wiggle an electron around it
produces an electromagnetic wave so
that's how radio waves work you're
taking in the antenna of your cell phone
or whatever else what's happening is in
the case of a cell phone like a billion
times a second you're you know you're
taking voltage you're reversing it
you're taking voltage you're reversing
it it's making the electrons go back and
forth back and forth inside the little
wire essentially that is the antenna in
the phone and every time the electrons
are made to wiggle back and forth
that wiggling process causes an
electromagnetic wave to be produced
causes radio wave to get generated the
same is true with visible light the same
is true with electrons in the metal
they're kind of wiggling around and
they're generating an electromagnetic
wave from their Wiggles but what's
happening is the electromagnetic wave
that comes in is generating Wiggles and
those Wiggles are now generating another
electromagnetic wave and it so happens
that the way the math works out the way
that comes in is produces Wiggles that
are precisely the ones that you need to
get a wave that's going back out in the
opposite direction to be what those The
Wiggles that are induced by the wave
coming in cause a wave going out in the
opposite direction to be produced
another way to think about this that
maybe is not quite as accurate is to
just say they're photons and they're
hitting this mirror and they're bouncing
off now you know what happens is in a
mirror
the the what the let's say it's the
photons are are they exactly bounce back
in the same direction that they came
from or they rather actually more
accurately if they if they hit it just
straight on they bounce back in the same
direction otherwise they follow the laws
of of momentum basically and if they hit
at an angle they bounce off at sort of
the opposite angle it's kind of like a a
um uh you know it's it's an elastic you
know the Billard ball that hits the side
of the table and bounces off off uh
reversing kind of coming back towards
you but continuing in the direction that
it was going in so that's called
specular reflection and that's what
happens in a metal and um other
materials are more complicated in the
way that they reflect photons and for
example a typical thing is that the
photons come in and for instance
so-called lurin reflectors um uh
materials that aren't shiny that don't
aren't mirrorlike
they tend to Photon comes in and it's
like photons on average come out at all
possible angles that's kind of like a
diffuse it's kind of like you can see it
because there is there's light being
reflected but it's not being reflected
in this mirror-like way so that's that's
how um uh it's roughly and so there's a
whole story well cataloged in computer
Graphics of the different ways in which
for example light can come in and most
of the photons come out in the specular
Direction but some of them don't and
they come out in this kind of cone
that's close to the specular Direction
they're usually some some numbers that
characterize how much spreading there is
and those very much affect our
perception of different materials of is
it shiny is it not is it is it these
different kinds of things but the
question of whether what we see in a
mirror is what's quotes really there um
yeah we don't have a lot of choice in
the fact that these um uh the photons
are essentially being sort of reflected
or the electromagnetic waves are being
uh sort of regenerated going back in the
in in the opposite direction and there's
nothing really that can be done with
that now having said that uh there
certainly are things that you can
imagine happening so for example let's
say that that mirror was not really a
mirror it was really something where
every little tiny piece of that mirror
is like a pixel and it's actually for
example a mems for example a
oh my gosh what does that stand for it's
a um okay so some materials if you put
an electric field on the material it
will change the mechanics of the
material so for example you put an
electric field the material the distance
between atoms will get slightly larger
or you put an electric field that that
that's a typical kind of thing to have
happen and so there are uh mems which I
now forgotten
micro oh my gosh micr mechanical but I'm
now forgetting what the acronym stands
for but anyway micromechanical devices
um where electrical electric Fields
voltages can change the mechanics of the
device so for example the um
uh the thing that um so so some
projectors computer projectors work this
way they have a mirror and it isn't
really an ordinary mirror it's a mirror
that's broken in tiny little pixels and
each pixel has this kind of electrical
effect so the the mirror can effectively
be turned by uh by voltage just like you
could you know change the uh switch on
or off a pixel in um on your screen by
changing in that case you're changing
the direction of molecules in a liquid
Crystal for example or you're doing
something uh some something else where
you're where little voltage for that
particular pixel is making it change so
similarly on this mirror you can have a
mirror that isn't really a mirror
because every pixel is sort of active
and being addressed and you can put a
voltage there or not put a voltage there
and the mirror doesn't show what the
mirror could have shown now another
thing that can happen with mirror like
things is Holograms so in a hologram
what you're doing is normally when you
reflect light it's like whatever light
comes in it just gets reflected but
let's say that there were details of how
you reflected the light that were small
enough that they're like the wavelength
of light they're they're about the size
of the wavelength of
light so normally light follows we're
used to light following what's usually
called geometrical
Optics you see it very clearly with
lasers you have a beam of laser light
you reflect the beam of laser light from
a mirror there'll be another beam that
comes back the the um uh from the mirror
most of the time like just goes sort of
in straight lines and it gets reflected
from mirrors and it's it's uh does all
these kinds of things okay so because
light can be thought of as made up of
this wave there is also a defraction
effect interference effects and you can
see that um convenient place to see that
is if you look at ripples in water and
you see let let's say that you've got
Ripples and you've you've kind of got
this this baffle where you're trying to
prevent the water from getting through
so you got these ripples coming up to
this baffle and uh then the ripples go
out and in the middle between those two
two sides the ripples will just keep
going straight forward but if you look
um at an angle sort of coming out from
that that opening there will be little
ripples that go off to the sides so in
other words you wouldn't be able to
they're not going in a straight line
they're not the ripples are not just
going straight out of the Port whatever
if that was in the ocean they are the
ripples are kind of going to the side
and that's because well it's if you
because effectively the way you think
about it is there's a there's a wave
that's kind of wiggling the water and at
every point that wave that when the wave
arrives somewhere it makes a wave that's
actually a circular wave but when you
combine those circular waves together in
the place where all the waves were kind
of lined up they just keep going in that
direction but places where there weren't
other waves a little piece of sort of
circle gets left over and you get uh
kind of the the ripples going out in the
direction that wasn't the straight line
Direction same thing happens with light
but it happens that effect happens only
on length scales that are of order of
the wavelength of light so typical light
uh let's see red light is um 500
nanometers which is um uh
um uh half a millionth of a meter is the
wavelength so when we talk about these
electromagnetic waves they are uh the
sort of the distance between the the The
Wiggles and the wave is to make red
light is is about half a million of a
meter and
so that um and so this defraction effect
only happens when you have like openings
that are com able to the wavelength of
light and so defraction is is um and so
what you can do is effectively have a
um uh if you have something which
is like a like a mirror or like a piece
of film that um can uh transmit light if
you have features there that are
comparable to the wavelength of light
you won't it won't be the case that the
light either goes straight through or
gets or gets blocked it can be the case
that it defract so it has it has this um
it can sort of go not in that straight
line Direction and in any case the way
that you make Holograms is by
essentially picking up
well it's it's kind of picking up the
wave structure of light and you can make
kind of a a mirror that essentially
causes you to reconstruct the exact
pattern of electromagnetic waves that
would correspond to some
three-dimensional object this I'm going
to have to explain a bit more to really
get get this clearly explained um but
just to say just for sort of for fun you
could imagine uh can't we don't know how
to do it yet but one could imagine
making a hologram in real time where you
have these little micro mirrors and
they're so small that they're comparable
to the wavelength of light and they're
all wiggling around and they're wiggling
around fast enough that you can actually
make this sort of 3D movie projected out
into empty space by making sort of the
pattern of electromagnetic waves
correspond to the pattern that would be
there if the actual physical objects
were sitting there in the
space
um
so ah mems microelectromechanical system
thank you I knew there was micr
mechanics in there I just couldn't
remember all micro electromechanical
thank you I'll try to remember that
um let's
see uh maybe one
more question
here
um huh time scroll is asking is there a
number like e or Pi that instead of
being small and 10 is
Big um how do these numbers get specific
notation and
names well you know you do lots of
things in math and some things show up
repeatedly like Pi shows up all over the
place it's the ratio of the
circumference to diameter of a circle
it's the thing that shows up you know if
you say are two numbers relatively prime
do they do they have um uh divisors in
common things that divide them in common
numbers that divide in common well the
fraction of numbers that aren't
relatively prime is six over uh that are
relatively prime is six over pi^ squ Pi
showed up again Pi shows up all over the
place it's it's a really common thing to
show up e shows up pretty often there
are other constants I think I mentioned
before the oila mascheroni constant
gamma is 0577 dot dot dot dot dot that
shows up much more rarely I mean I'll
tell you where that shows up if you take
the sum of 1 /
n with n going up to
Infinity well that sum diverges it's
infinite but if you subtract log n no
I'm sorry if you if you take that sum up
to an upper limit of let's say K and you
subtract log K the limit of that as K
goes to Infinity is that 0577 number and
that number appears somewhat often not
as often as e and pi and that's a sort
of ranking of which kinds of numbers
which sort of pack packets of
mathematics occur repeatedly and and
that's really what determines the things
we give names to in mathematics it's
very similar to the way we give names to
things in natural language you know by
the time we've seen a chair a bunch of
times it's worth giving it a name by the
Su we've seen a live stream a bunch of
times it's worth giving it a name and
it's uh so it's the same thing in
mathematics when when things in the
natural course of mathematics show up
repeatedly they get given names so you
know the co addition very common
operation it's get given a name you know
exponentiation number raised to power
it's given a name the the operation of
repeated exponentiation is much rarer
it's usually given a name it has various
different names like power towers and
tetration and so on it's kind of on the
edge of having a name because it's on
the edge of being widely enough used
that it's worth it having a name and you
know in a sense any any quantity you can
you know you can imagine imine you can
work out any number 572 4864 blah blah
blah blah blah going off to Infinity you
could give that number a name if you
wanted to there obviously an infinite
number of numbers like that so you'd end
up with an infinite number of names and
that wouldn't be terribly useful but the
place where you give names to things is
where they appear repeatedly now it's a
question of the structure of
mathematics sort of how how common a
particular name is here's an interesting
example if you go to from Alpha and you
type in some number. 52 3 4 6 whatever
it is one of the pods that will produce
as output is it will say possible closed
forms for this number okay so let's say
the number we typed in was
075 okay so most people would know that
that's 3 over4
3/4 let's say we typed in the number 77
okay that's 77 out of over 100 but maybe
77 I don't know let me give you another
example
3.14159 okay so you could write that as
314,000 blah blah blah blah blah divided
by some denominator it's also roughly pi
and so our little thing for estimating
sort of guessing what the closed form
formula for a number is it tries to
trade off oh it's this thing 3.31 4159
divided by a million or something versus
it's just called pi and it's sort of an
interesting thing because you know any
given number you can there'll be some
formula for that number at least to the
number of digits you've specified it
might be the square root of the cube
root of seven minus the the the fifth
root of six etc etc etc some very onate
thing or to that Precision it might be a
named constant there aren't that many
named constants I mean the ones that are
that are really quite common uh you know
pi is probably the alltime winner
followed by E there's also the golden
ratio sare 5+ 1 over two that's somewhat
common the oil mascaron constant I think
called Catalan constant that shows up in
uh in working out counting the number of
trees that you get there's another thing
called kinin constant that comes up in
continued fractions but by the time
those are the ones that are in Mor from
language and and mathematic has built in
things because those are the ones that
that we're really tailing off
in in how common they are you know by
the time you're at kin's constant it's
really pretty rare it's not a very
commonly occurring thing
so but so this question of what gets a
name it's things that occur commonly
there's sort of a big debate on whether
pi over two should have um should have
its own name sometimes people say well
Pi is this thing with two legs and maybe
we should call to the thing with one leg
namely pi over two so to speak the half
of the pi and actually we did an
analysis a number of years ago of
whether uh you know whether that
actually makes sense because you can
just look at all the formulas that are
out there that people are put in papers
and things like that and say when pi
occurs does it occur divided by two or
not and the answer was it's it's not
really that convincing Pi occurs more
often as you know three times pi this
thing not always pi over two so that's
some
uh that's kind of the story of that it's
sort of an interesting thing to ask the
question sort of what can we learn about
mathematics by looking at the
distribution of these packages of
mathematics that occur repeatedly
similar to what do we learn about human
language you know we know in human
language there's this thing called Zips
law that says that if we rank words in
English in order of how commonly they're
used like the and a and so on be very
common words and uh you know rhinoceros
will be a common word and what is that
word flossy Pocky
nil
nification which is um some semi madeup
word but that would be a very rare word
um but it's in many dictionaries I think
oh anti
disestablishmentarianism that's a that's
a common long word that's pretty rare
but lots of words that are that are rare
um and if we rank these words in terms
of the most frequent word to the least
frequent word out of the 50,000 words
that are common in English for example
it turns out that the nth most common
word in English has frequency roughly
one over n it's called Zips law nobody
really knows why it's true there are
some possible theories for it but that
type of distribution is very common in
lots of places and I remember we worked
this out oh gosh 20 something years ago
we worked out that same distribution for
mathematical constants and uh no
actually we worked it out I'm sorry we
worked it out for letters that people
use like Alpha Beta gamma and so on
people use in mathematical formulas so
I'm not sure I don't think there are
quite enough mathematical constants to
be be able to work that out but my guess
is that if we go from PI to e to these
other things that we'll see a similar
kind of uh less and less frequent use of
the that that particular thing so it's
an interesting question whether actually
is kind of interesting and I should
think about this the um if you look at
uh mathematical formulas that show up in
practice and you look at sort of clumps
of of stuff in those
formulas what and this is like the pyus
TOA question what are the lumps of stuff
that appear repeatedly in these formulas
and what what's their frequency and so
on and I think that's uh and and does
that give one some indication is it the
case that if you have a meaningful
mathematical paper it's probably going
to have this particular distribution let
me give you an example of something like
that there's a very weird fact there's
this thing called benford's law and what
it says is this the the um if you have a
bunch of numbers that show up in I don't
know accounting statements you've got
numbers of dollars or you've got um uh
some other or you're looking at um a
table of of physical constants and there
you know there's different constants
that appear and so on and so on okay
weird
fact the leading
digits in those numbers are not equally
frequent so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine zero
well up to nine they're not equally
frequent one is more common two is less
and there's a distribution where one is
the most common and it goes down to nine
which is the least common and
so the uh uh this is something where
when you just take numbers and you're
adding them up and you're doing
computations on them the reason it
happens this way is
because when the number gets bigger okay
so you you're doing things on a number
like seven and eventually you'll add
four to it and it'll make and make 11
and now it's got leading digit one and
this whole process of sort of adding
things to numbers and so on it doesn't
it means that the numbers tend to be
well they're kind of it's not the digits
that are equally distributed it's kind
of the size of numbers is equally
distributed but when you turn that into
digits the it is more common to have the
number start with a one because that's
the sort of more how to explain this
there
uh it's that sort of by the time you've
got to nine
you've almost got a bigger number and
then it would start with a one again
that's not a great explanation but in
any case the result is this this law
that is true for many numbers that just
sort of appear from doing arithmetic and
things it's not true for all numbers
it's not true for for example the primes
I don't think follow benford's law but
it's true for a lot of numbers that are
just made by doing standard arithmetic
operations so that means that you can uh
it's much more common to see um uh
to for example in um uh if you're trying
to work out did somebody cook these
numbers up did they fake him uh a good
test is do the numbers follow benford's
law actually rather embarrassingly
during the pandemic there were places
where you could look at the the reported
numbers of cases and things and they
definitely didn't follow benford's law
and this is a bad sign of these numbers
weren't really what they should have
been so to speak they were just kind of
made up um but this is a thing that
people use as a kind of test of whether
you know when you've got a bunch of
accounting uh data you know were these
numbers just made up or were they
actually the result of the actual
operations of a company or something
like this but that's another place
that's a place where just because of the
sort of structure of numbers with digits
you get this different uh number so you
know ones are more common than nines and
so on um that uh anyway so so so this
whole question about sort of
how packages of mathematical
functionality occur when they occur
repeatedly and so on is um uh is
something one could study and it's been
studied a bit there's probably more that
could be studied about it um in a sense
this question of when do repeated lumps
of mathematical work computational work
occur that's in a sense the role well in
human language we're making up words
whenever a repeated concept occurs in
mathematics we might make up a notation
when a repeated concept occurs in
computation that's the role of language
designers like well me um for to figure
out in a computational language when are
there repeated kind of lumps of
computational work which we should give
a name to an Implement a function to do
that and that's kind of the the and
again with welome language uh there's
also a distribution of how common
different functions are in typical
programs and I think it's a a zip law
type distribution again
where things like table are really
common and things like fold pair list
are much less common why exactly this
happens it's really unclear the fact
that there are these kinds of
quantitative laws of meaningful stuff
probably is very related to why there
are all sorts of uh scaling laws and so
on that happen in llms that you know in
large language models and you know the
innards of chat GPT and so on there are
all kinds of quantitative results that
are known that are important in figuring
out for example how much effort it's
worth going to to train the model and
how long it's going to take and and all
those kinds of things um and I think uh
um the uh uh that that's um uh that
that's kind of a
um uh so so this this kind of the
frequency of things when things are
meaningful is something we don't
understand very well but there seem to
be some sort of universal laws of that
uh okay robot Watcher is asking how many
digits of pi can you recite at this
moment not very many
3.14159
2653 blah so I only made it to
809 one question is why are those digits
So
Random
and we we know that the digits of piie
will never repeat that was proved
100 about 150 years ago
uh we know that the digits of pi will
never correspond to things like square
roots cube roots of numbers and so on
but we don't know much else about the
digits of pi we don't know for sure that
for example every digit one through nine
one you know zero through nine occurs
with equal frequency probably does
people have looked at that up to now
there are trillion digits of pi that
have been computed and it looks like all
the digits with equal frequency but
nobody's ever been able to prove that
and for example there are places in pi
where you have the uh z0000 Z for a
bunch of zeros and there's a certain
probability for that to happen with
there n zeros the probability is roughly
10us n so it seems because the digits
seem to be being generated randomly
actually the fact that you can kind of
get every string of digits in pi leads
to some fun stuff like like a few years
ago on Pi Day of the century that's uh
three March
14 uh 15 March 14th
2015 uh we made this website still
running called my
pay.com where you type in your birthday
and it will find where in pi is your
birthday so for example if your birthday
was uh
3415 be right at the beginning of Pi but
if your birthday was you know whatever
you know 829 whatever um it would be
much later in pi and for any birthday
you can find it in pi and it's believed
that for any sequence of digits you can
find it in pi but nobody's ever proved
that nobody knows that for sure it's one
of the it's a it's an old unsolved
problem in mathematics to to prove that
and it's not known for any of those
kinds of numbers like square root two or
or or the exponential constant e any of
those numbers it's not known that uh the
the structure of the digit sequence is
not known known that well and it's kind
of a it's kind of an interesting thing
because the um it's sort of a case where
even though the description of Pi is
quite simple the digits once generated
seem quite random this is a phenomenon
that I've studied a lot in computational
systems it's actually a very common
phenomenon that even though the rules
are quite simple the things once
generated seem random but in any case
the the the thing that um happens with
pi the reason it's hard to recite digits
of pi whatever is because they're kind
of random
there isn't you know we can't really
make a pattern to them it's kind of like
in order to make a pattern to them to
help you remember them you are sort of
imposing that pattern on them it's kind
of like constellations of stars and Sky
there really isn't a bull you know in
the tus constellation or something um
that uh you know that's that's arranges
the Stars it's just that we humans say
oh well it's kind of reminiscent of this
thing this this thing that exists in our
world that sort of happens to correspond
to this piece of Randomness and I'm sure
people who memorize digits at Pi they're
they're probably remembering they're
sort of chunking It Up by remembering
the rhythm of this collection of digits
is a bit like this Rhythm that I
remember from this other place and
that's kind of that tends to be how our
memory Works um but in uh this it's a
it's a a good example of one of the many
kind of sort of easy to state hard to
establish results in mathematics is the
apparent randomness of digits of pi and
there's much that's been made people
have noticed that sort of some apparent
Randomness in which numbers are prime
but the regularities there are
regularities that have been found in the
distribution of primes and those
regularities have been much studied that
leads to thing called prime number
theorem leads to the reman hypothesis is
an unsolved problem about the randomness
of the primes and so on but this is sort
of a a characteristic front Frontier of
mathematics that really hasn't moved
much in the case of the digits of P that
hasn't really moved much in 100 years um
to figure out more about how that works
anyway so that's my excuse for not being
able to recite more digits of pi is they
really are quite random uh with respect
or they seem to be uh even though they
have a rule to generate them they they
seem to have um uh uh they seem random
once
generated all right well I should stop
there and thanks for some interesting
questions here and uh see you another
time bye for
now